bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans cette nouvelle vidéo dédiée à
moonlight l'épisode iv vient de sortir
ce qu'il signifie que nous avons fait
plus de la moitié du chemin puisque la
série ne dure que six épisodes et
sincèrement il y a plein de choses
intéressantes à dire bien évidemment on
reparlera de moonlight à la fin de la
série car évidemment ce héros reviendra
dans l'avenir du mc eu donc on aura du
travail soyez en sûr en attendant je
vous propose d'éclaircir certains points
d'essayer d'émettre quelques petites
théorie et pourquoi pas expliquer
certaines choses comme notamment la fin
de l'épisode iv qui en a perturbé plus
d'un et les qui est très particulier
beaucoup de choses proviennent des
comics on va en parler je vous avais
retirer quand on va en parler parce que
je comprends que certains n'ai pas envie
de se faire spoiler par les comics donc
voilà bref sur ce commençons tout
d'abord je vous propose de nous
concentrer sur le trouble dissociatif de
l'identité de marque car nous avons
encore très peu de réponses là dessus
nous avions déjà parler plus en détails
de l'origine story de moon knight dans
une précédente vidéo et vous êtes
beaucoup à la connaître donc on ne va
pas s'attarder là dessus en détail dans
les tous premiers comics de moon knight
on nous fait sous entendre que le
trouble dissociatif de l'identité de
marque est apparu plus ou moins en même
temps qu'il soit revenu à la vie pour
devenir ce moon knight finalement par le
biais de comics plus récents qui
étoffent l'histoire du héros et dont la
série semble s'inspirer on nous apprend
que marc qui est normalement l'identité
principal a subi un certain traumatisme
est un jeune qui a donné naissance à son
trouble de l'identité et c'est déjà un
point intéressant a mentionné car la
série nous a introduits dans la vie de
steven grant une des entités de marque
spector et ce dernier n'avait aucunement
conscience que son corps se partager
entre plusieurs personnes tout comme
marc d'ailleurs ce dernier nous apprend
que ce partage de corse effectué depuis
quelque temps mais pas non plus au point
que ce soit depuis l'enfance nous ne
savons pas encore tous d origine de
marque et il ya de grandes chances que
la série exploite toute cette partie
nous allons y revenir un peu plus tard
mais il semblerait que nous allons
plonger dans le for intérieur de
l'esprit de marc et que cela nous
dévoile plusieurs vérités pour que
moonlight évolué vers une version
meilleur de lui même pour le moment par
le biais de l'épisode 3 et 4 marvel n'a
amené que brièvement la véritable
origine de marque spector des comics
l'époque où il était mercenaires et où
le père de leïla le grand archéologue a
été tué par rool bochmann leïla est
clairement l'adaptation de marlène des
comics la femme de mark spector et la
fille d'halle ron le grand archéologue
qui a découvert la tombe de caoutchouc
mais voilà pour revenir au trouble
dissociatif de l'identité ce qui est
intéressant c'est que marc se souvient
très clairement de son passé tandis que
steven est introduit directement dans le
présent sans aucune mention de son passé
il apprend même au fil du temps ce que
marc a pu faire à l'époque ce qui
sous-entendrait que le trouble
dissociatif de l'identité de marque soit
possiblement apparu après avoir été tués
durant le raid où il était mercenaires
puis ramené à la vie par comme chou
néanmoins tout reste possible concernant
ce trouble et il ya des chances que la
fin de la série nous en apprennent
davantage sur son origine le trouble
dissociatif de marque nous est présenté
comme un problème depuis le début de la
série marque et steven sont toujours en
confrontation ou en désaccord alors
qu'en vérité ce trouble est plutôt une
force puisque mark a des aptitudes que
steven n'a pas et inversement et comme
dans les comics il y a de fortes chances
qu'ils apprennent à cohabiter et à
s'entraider après tout leurs premières
réactions dans l'hôpital psychiatrique
c'est de se faire un câlin marque et
steven s'apprécie l'un l'autre
finalement d'ailleurs concernant ce
trouble dissociatif de l'identité
les fans de comics vous le savez autant
que moi mac spector a normalement trois
identités bien distinctes si on enlève
le moonlight il y as marck spector
l'identité principal bien évidemment le
mercenaire il y à steven grant qui est à
la base un riche play-boy ici réécrit en
expert de l'egypte antique et vendeurs
dans un musée et enfin il reste jake
look lit un chauffeur de taxi et un
débrouillard qui récupère des
informations
en gros quand mark a eu une absence lors
de l'épisode 3 et qu'il a tué tout le
monde il a accusé stephen d'avoir repris
le corps et fait un massacre sauf que
steven dément totalement l'avoir fait
c'est obligé pour moi qu'il s'agissait
de jeff klauk lit d'ailleurs lors de son
trip dans l'hôpital psychiatrique marque
retrouve steven enfermé dans un
sarcophage il va le libérer mais dans
une pièce juste à côté nous retrouvons
un autre sarcophage que mark va
totalement ignorée il est sûr à 1000%
qu'il s'agisse de jake look lit la
dernière identité qui semble ne pas
avoir été encore réveillé ou du moins
que marc et steven n'ont pas encore
réalisé je pense personnellement que
marvel a fait le choix de repousser jake
pour le moment car cela aurait été
peut-être un petit peu trop complexe un
héros avec trois identités dès le début
de la série les premiers épisodes se
sont pas mal enchaîné s'était peut-être
même un peu compliqué à suivre par
moment rien qu'avec deux identités donc
avec 3 voilà quoi mais maintenant que
nous avons bien assimilé les identités
de marque spector et de steven grant et
bien je pense qu'il est maintenant temps
de pourquoi pas nous instaurer la
troisième identité qui est jeff klauk
lit ensuite il va être temps pour nous
de nous intéresser à la fin de l'épisode
iv et de tout ce que cela peut impliquer
pour les derniers épisodes je vais être
franc avec vous il est clair que
moonlight possède énormément
d'inspiration de l'histoire des comics
néanmoins on reste dans de la
réadaptation pour le mc eu donc tout est
possible en soit ce que je veux dire par
là précisément c'est que je pense
personnellement que marc est mort dans
l'épisode 4 arthur rôle a bien tué
d'ailleurs dans les comics marque
une deuxième fois mais ce n'est pas
aussi simple et c'est pour ça que nous
devons parler du passage de l'hôpital
psychiatrique
cet arc provient des comics de jeff les
meilleures sorties en 2016 en gros
marque est en train de mourir et va
effectuer une sorte de voyage spirituel
qui va l'envoyer dans un hôpital
psychiatrique
tout comme dans la fin de l'épisode
marque ne comprend pas trop ce qu'il se
passe il fait face à des aides soignants
il retrouve les personnages qu'il a
connu dans sa vie passée en tant que
patient de l'hôpital et sera confrontée
également un docteur qui la côtoyaient
auparavant et qui lui affirmera que son
passé provient en fait de sa maladie et
de sa folie tout ça on le retrouve dans
l'épisode marque ne comprend pas trop ce
qu'il se passe il retrouve dans cet
hôpital les gens qu'il a connus comme
donna qui était sa patronne leïla les
hommes et femmes demain de arthur arthur
qui est ici le docteur et directeur de
l'hôpital on retrouve également plein de
références aux épisodes précédents comme
les cupcakes de l'épisode 1 un tableau
faisant référence aux alpes endroit où
mark a récupéré le scarabée on retrouve
un dessin de caunes show la can d'arthur
ainsi que ses sandales bref tout ça pour
nous faire comprendre que tout ce que
l'on a vécu dans les premiers épisodes
proviendraient en fait de l'esprit de
marc qui a du mal à faire la part des
choses entre la réalité et ses rêves
sauf qu'en fait il existe des réponses
concernant la fin de cet épisode et là
je dois vous mettre en garde on va
parler plus en détail des comics de jeff
les meilleurs il y a de très grandes
chances que ces derniers nous apporte
les réponses qui nous manque concernant
la série donc voilà si vous ne voulez
pas prendre le risque d'être spoiler
même s'il peut y avoir des réadaptations
et cetera et bien je vous invite à
rejoindre le time code affiché à l'écran
en gros c'est hôpital psychiatrique est
un moyen de piéger l'esprit de marque au
premier abord effectivement les docteurs
et aides soignants font tout leur
possible pour faire croire à marcq qu'il
est en plein délire et que c'est lui
problème en réalité la vérité est cachée
à marcq et ce dernier réussira à voir ce
qu'il ne peut pas voir il est en fait
dans un endroit qui sera catégorisé
comme lover void les docteurs et autres
aides soignants sont finalement des
dieux d'égypte est pire que ça le grand
docteur et directeur de l'hôpital est en
fait une représentation
damit la déesse du jugement à tête de
crocodile par rapport à la fin de
l'épisode 4 il semblerait que marc et
steven ont compris que l'hôpital clocher
et qu'il était fake et que justement il
commence à voir véritablement ce qu'il
aurait été caché puisque ces derniers
voient au final une divinité égyptienne
en tant qu'aide soignante et par rapport
à arthur euro qui est l'avatar damit et
bien cela concorderait avec les comics
puisque arthur serait au final la déesse
égyptienne qui tentent de piéger marque
et ses autres personnalités pour le mc
eu également je pense personnellement qu
avec la mort de mark par arthur le but
serait de piéger définitivement marque
dans son esprit car au final étant
l'avatar de kenshoo marque peut renaître
grâce aux dieux de la lune et donc c'est
un risque pour arthur et à hamit d'être
contré ce qu'ils veulent éviter à tout
prix au final dans les comics il va
s'avérer que ce road trip spirituelle
qui se déroule en quelque sorte dans la
tête de marc était l'oeuvre de kenshoo
dans le but que marc guérisse de son
trouble dissociatif de l'identité et on
en revient à ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure depuis le début de la série le
trouble dissociatif de l'identité nous
est présenté comme un problème est une
complication marque et steven ont même
l'espoir qu'après avoir vécu arthur et à
hamit les choses reviennent à la normale
et ne partageront plus le même corps
sauf que c'est quelque chose qui
n'arrivera jamais et il va falloir
qu'ils en prennent conscience tout comme
dans les comics de jeff les meilleurs au
début marqué ses autres identités sont
en conflit car ils veulent se
débarrasser du trouble dissociatif de
l'identité et ne plus partager le même
corps mais par le biais du road trip
spirituel imposé par coach ou un marque
au plus bas est en train de mourir ce
dernier a finalement comprendre et
apprendre que ce trouble dissociatif de
l'identité n'est pas un problème est
qu'au contraire c'est même une force et
une condition qui le rend encore plus
unique et qui fait partie de lui à la
fin de l'arc marque embrassera son
trouble dissociatif et sera un nouvel
homme qui s'affirmera et partagera son
corps avec ses autres identité sans
aucun problème rendant par conséquent le
moonlight encore plus puissant et
cohabitant à la perfection avec kontchou
également c'est quelque chose que l'on
va retrouver dans la série c'est sur le
câlin entre steven et marc est le
premier pas vers cette symbiose les deux
identités s'apprécie au final et seront
encore plus fusionnelle au fil de leur
road trip spirituel néanmoins il y a
quand même matière à débattre puisque en
soi comme show est emprisonné donc pour
moi normalement marque ne peut pas
renaître actuellement à mon avis il
faudrait que quelqu'un le libère en soit
vu qu'il est enfermé dans l'endroit
secret où se trouvent les nehad il se
pourrait que ce soit les autres dieux
égyptiens qui le libère quand ils
verront qu'arthur et hamit sont
véritablement hostile et que leur seul
espoir est finalement coach ou et son
avatar alors il se pourrait que
l'épisode 5 soit leur trip spirituel
complet de marque avec steven et
possiblement du coup jeff klauk lit avec
la possible libération de caunes chaud
jusqu'à la renaissance de marque par le
dieu de la lune et de la vengeance
tandis qu'arthur est en train
d'effectuer l'avènement retour damit la
fin de l'épisode 5 pourrait être donc la
renaissance de marque et l'épisode 6
serait la bataille finale d'ailleurs
petite théorie par rapport à la bataille
finale mais étant donné qu'il semblerait
que marc avance vers une acceptation
totale de lui même et son trouble avec
une pure symbiose avec steven est
certainement jake à chaque fin de série
nous voyons que la lune devient de plus
en plus plein il est facile de se douter
que l'épisode 6 symbolisera la pleine
lune est-ce qu'il se pourrait qu'à la
fin de la série pour la bataille finale
nous soyons témoin d'une sorte de knight
ultime comme lors des événements de
l'âge de caunes chaud dans les comics
moi je vois bien une forme de moonlight
encore plus puissantes du à l'avènement
spirituel de marque alliée à la pleine
lune pour affronter un arthur combinée
avec la ds à hamit au sommet de leur
forme bref c'est une idée comme ça enfin
il est temps de rattraper mon retard et
de vous parler de ce dont je n'avais pas
pu vous parler car il y à du lourd qui
peut arriver à l'avenir dans le mc eu
concernant moon knight dans l'épisode 1
et 2 il y à la présence d'un qr code qui
vous mène vers le site marvel où vous
pourrez lire gratuitement les comics
numéro 32 et 33 de where he walked by
night sorti vers 1975 si je ne dis pas
de bêtises c'est très intéressant c'est
historique car le comics 32 werewolf
signifie la première véritable
apparition de moon knight dans les
comics marvel mais choses encore plus
intéressantes
wolf by night est un antihéros qui est
beaucoup liée à moon knight dans son
histoire un spécial halloween est
d'ailleurs prévue cette année pour ce
personnage sur dix n'est plus et du coup
cela peut vouloir dire que moonlight
pourrait nous introduire where he walked
by night dans le mc hugh d'ici la fin de
la série mais attendait cela va même
encore plus loin que ça car wolf dans
les comics qui est un humain du nom de
jane russell s'est fait mordre par une
femme loup garou qui travaille pour
dracula et là cela devient très
intéressant car beaucoup de rumeurs nous
parlait que blade pourrait faire
pourquoi pas une apparition dans
moonlight d'ici la fin de la série et
franchement c'est une possibilité wolf
est un protagoniste pas mal lié à blade
et dracula est un grand ennemi de blade
et moon knight dans les comics vous le
savez comme moi nous sommes beaucoup à
nous attendre à voir un jour
l'apparition du groupe des mines itunes
dans le mca est franchement plus on
avance plus la route se trace pour nous
donner une représentation de ce groupe
effectivement blade a été teasé dans
eternal en allant à la rencontre de dane
wissmann le black knight tous deux ont
fait partie des mines night sound là
maintenant avec l'intégration de
moonlight et wolf dans le spécial
halloween si ce n'est avant et bien eux
aussi ont fait partie des mines sohn ses
personnages amène de nouveaux aspects
dans le mc eu les monstres horrifique
comme les vampires les loups garous et
cetera les dieux égyptiens ou encore le
passé sombre de la famille de dane mais
surtout ce qui réunit ses héros c'est
tout le côté violent et sombre qu'ils
ont en eux j'ai vraiment hâte de voir
tout ça se relier dans l'avenir du mc eu
il est fort probable que nous ayons une
grosse surprise dans la scène post
générique de moonlight et pour conclure
on va parler d'une petite théorie qui a
fait le tour lors des premiers épisodes
et d'une chose énorme que j'attends moi
depuis le début de la série et qui me
tient vraiment à coeur premièrement
certains pensent qu arthur euro pourrait
être victor von doom alias le docteur
doom l'idée et je trouve à la base
intéressante mais en réalité la théorie
ne tient pas vraiment tant que ça la
route et personnellement j'attendrais
mieux comme intégration pour ben dr doom
quoi c'est un sacré personnage tout part
à la base du fameux château aperçu dans
l'épisode 1 qui se trouvent dans les
alpes doctor doom est connue notamment
pour son château qui se trouvent
normalement en laque very situés en
europe le château est l'endroit où mark
semble avoir volé scarabées et où les
hommes de main d'arthur l'ont poursuivi
le château semblerait appartenir à
arthur surtout étant donné qu'il donne
sur le petit village où il est considéré
presque comme une divinité par ses
habitants après certains parlent du fait
également qu arthur est un but lui même
qu'il se sent supérieur comme le docteur
doom sans oublier que victor est un as
des fausses identités bon je vous avoue
que je trouve que c'est très tirée par
les cheveux mais la théorie du château
en vrai c'était pas mal surtout vu que
le dr doom possède un château rempli
d'artefacts donc le scarabée aurait pu
s'y retrouver bon bref bon et du coup la
chose que j'attends le plus depuis le
début de la série et c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui me hype de fou c'est
une référence à rama tout pour les non
connaisseurs rama tout est l'une des
identités de quang le conquérant une
identité de coups et women's présenté
dans la série law qui en gros quand il
était au 31ème siècle nathaniel
richard's ses lacets de l'époque
paisible dans laquelle il vivait et
enviée l'époque des avengers après avoir
fait la découverte d'une vieille machine
à voyager dans le temps nathaniel a
fabriqué la sienne sous la forme d'un
sphinx et est allé dans le passé pendant
la période où l'egypte antique était à
son apogée là bas il s'est érigé en
pharaon et a pris le nom de rama tout
grâce à sa technologie du futur rama
tout a régné pendant un moment et a
marqué au fer rouge l'époque de l'egypte
antique d'ailleurs quand il deviendra
qu'anglo conquérant à un moment donné il
se lassera des conquêtes et repartira
encore une fois dans l'egypte antique où
il reprendra encore une fois son rôle de
farah où en tant que rama tout il ira
même jusqu à s'enfermer dans un
sarcophage pendant un long moment avant
de finalement revenir pour contrer celui
du passé devenu qu'anglo conquérant et
deviendra par la suite la forme finale
de nathaniel immo russe alors cela peut
paraître compliqué pour certains mais je
vous conseille de vous abonner à la
chaîne car on va bientôt parler de tout
ça en profondeur bref tout ça pour dire
que j'étais comme un ouf pendant
l'épisode iv je m'attendais vraiment à
voir une référence à ramat hôtes durant
l'épisode nous avons eu dans l'épisode 5
de la série de loki le sphinx qui
servait de vaisseau arrahma tout donc
nous savons qu'il a existé dans le mc
hugh donc quand stevens extase d'avoir
trouvé une tombe secrète d'un phare à
oublier je voulais vraiment que ce soit
rama tout en tout cas je suis sûr et
franchement je l'espère vraiment qu'il y
aura une référence car ce qui est
intéressant c'est que lors de son règne
en tant que pharaon ramatou de
s'intéresser justement aux origines
d'apocalypse le tout premier mutants qui
était surpuissant rama tout voulait le
contrôler en faire son disciple c'est
l'une des raisons de son voyage dans le
passé donc pour le mc où nous pourrions
avoir un ram à tout qui auraient voyagé
dans l'egypte antique afin de devenir
pourquoi pas l'avatar d'un dieu égyptien
dans le but d'avoir des pouvoirs
exceptionnels lui permettant de devenir
encore plus puissant et dangereux
imaginez un seul instant si rama tout
avait été pourquoi pas un avatar dany où
aller pourquoi pas de coach au karément
ce serait juste la pure folie et cela
permettrait encore une fois de relier
toutes les oeuvres entre elles et
d'introduire encore une fois ce fameux
ennemis iconique les gangs le conquérant
alors je sais qu'il ya une référence à
rama tout dans l'épisode 3 nous voyons
une sorte de tête de pharaon sur la
veste du jeune personnage qu'affronte
marque mais bon ce n'est rien de bien
concret déjà cela peut ne pas être rama
tout et en plus de ça cela semble juste
être possiblement un simple easter egg
comme ça sans aucune raison derrière en
tout cas sachez qu'à chaque épisode de
moonlight j'attends de voir une belle
référence à rama tout
bon jeu peut souffler en vrai on a parlé
de plein de choses dans cette vidéo je
suis très content de l'avoir fait je
voulais vous parler de moonlight et ses
mystères actuelle bien évidemment les
choses vont encore avancé avec la fin de
la série et puis l'avenir le futur du mc
eu un parce que neiter reviendra
évidemment donc voilà on se mettra à
jour avec de nouvelles vidéos en temps
voulu sur ce j'espère que ma vidéo vous
aura plu n'hésitez pas à me faire part
en commentaire de vos idée de ce que
vous avez remarqué dans la série de vos
théories c'est toujours un plaisir de
vous lire sachez le puits n'hésitez pas
à vous abonner comme je vous disais on
va reparler en détail de quang le
conquérant avec le nouveau concept que
je prépare actuellement et du coup cela
s'étend aussi à d'autres comics marvel
etc bref j'en dis pas plus puis
n'hésitez pas non plus aussi a laissé un
petit pouce bleus et puis voilà quoi
écoutez cet argot rock que le lay en
garde sont avec vous allez ciao tout le
monde
[Musique]